hey BuzzFeed it's Stephanie poetry and
I'm gonna answer 30 questions in 3
minutes
let's get it the five oh my gosh
Shailene Woodley texts the it's like
Nero to me nobody
Stephanie annoying loud oh my god
it's G hates me um am i doing that like
was like this but then takes up like
avoid me like like that my laptop use
brown eyeliner to look snatched but
natural oh it's 2 per minute for me I'm
like indecisive shouldn't cut it
wouldn't
Nick theatres right I would bring a boat
water food I would bring Jackson wings
each debris a bunch of chapstick and
our bank oh my gosh um
BuzzFeed girl oh my gosh ran away
Eric Nam when people are rude to people
are helping you
milk tea without boba unless ice like
nuts like anything nutty fingers on my
feet boy Mayo cuz like I mean I will say
Jackson was actually general tweet any
any any tweet that has the walk or do
you like my hair today
yes all right I did it
30 questions in three minutes that was
fun I was exciting thank you so much
BuzzFeed I can't wait to come back but
before I leave I want you all to listen
to my new collaboration with Jackson
Wayne called I Love You 3000 - it's
gonna be late okay
[Music]